Komputery kwantowe rozwiązują problemy, z którymi nie radzą sobie
komputery klasyczne — takie jak
znalezienie odpowiednich materiałów do
wychwytywania dwutlenku węgla, żeby naprawdę
podjąć walkę ze zmianami klimatu, czy opracowanie
wydajniejszych nawozów, które
nie szkodzą ziemi, a jednocześnie podtrzymują
łańcuch dostaw żywności potrzebny do wyżywienia świata.
Są też fundamentalne pytania o to, jak zbudowany jest nasz wszechświat
i jak materia zachowuje się na poziomie atomowym
i subatomowym — to wiedza, którą musimy zdobyć.
To kolejna granica do przekroczenia.
Przyjrzyjmy się jednej dziedzinie, w której badania są już prowadzone:
poszukiwaniu nowych baterii.
Baterie odmieniły nasze życie, umożliwiając nam noszenie
komputerów i smartfonów,
ale jest jeszcze wiele do zrobienia. Baterie są kluczowe
dla naszej czystej energetycznej przyszłości —
czy to do zasilania samochodów elektrycznych, czy naprawdę
do napędzania energii odnawialnej.
Potrzebujemy fundamentalnie innej chemii,
żeby tworzyć baterie
jutra. Obliczenia kwantowe
pozwoliłyby nam zajrzeć do wnętrza baterii
podczas jej bardzo złożonych reakcji, co umożliwiłoby nam
myślenie o nowych materiałach
i strukturze baterii, które będą potrzebne
do zasilania urządzeń następnej generacji.
Jak to osiągnąć? Budując najbardziej zaawansowane urządzenia kwantowe na świecie
i platformę deweloperską,
i udostępniając je całemu światu.
Tylko współpracując teraz,
będziemy w stanie rozwiązać problemy, z którymi będziemy
razem się mierzyć w przyszłości.